are you satisfied by all the answers by
the end of part two yeah I would say
fans would be friends would be really
happy with
it shows us here we are after the
cancellation of manifest back for the
fourth season how does that feel I mean
it feels amazing it feels like you know
we got a second chance that we didn't
think we would get and we get to finish
the story now um but it's like thanks to
the fans like it's it's crazy to see
what hashtagging and what tweeting and
what rallying can do to a show I mean
I've seen it happen to other shows but
to actually have it happen to us is
really really cool when did it become
real for you like the moment you were
like oh we really are coming back I mean
I I work in Hollywood it's not real
until you're on set shooting it so
that's what's so real what is the number
one question you're most excited for
fans to get the answer to I mean the
obvious what happened to the plane
um but also just what happens to them
now like what happens when they do
figure it out
um and we do get to kind of get a
glimpse of that so really exciting for
for us to share that so we kick off with
a two-year time job which is significant
how has life changed for the stone
family I mean it's changed a lot
um we left off with Grace dying so that
was huge it's okay
[Music]
you know what we need to do now
obviously that's gonna have you know
Ripple effects into the entire family
but so we pick up with Ben in his grief
but that now leaves Michaela to kind of
pick up the pieces of solving the
mystery of what happened to the plane on
her own because Ben is so far you know
gone that she she doesn't have her
co-pilot her partner her brother there
to help her figure things out to go on
callings with her
um and so she's kind of left to herself
and then at the same time Jared told
Michaela that he thought Zeke was gonna
die and that's the only reason he let
Zeke marry Michaela so there's this big
conversation there's this Cloud hanging
over their heads of like what's gonna
happen with the love triangle and we
also get to see what happened with the
conversation or conversations around
that so it's starting really messy
really messy and also Cal is now older
two years ago I touched the tail fin and
disappeared again
then came back five years older yes
you know it feels like Cal is guilty of
killing his wife as well there's tension
there and Michaela and Cal kind of form
this really they've already formed this
but it it deepens
um their relationship deepens because
Cal has nowhere else to go now
um he can't talk to his dad he can't
talk to his sister
um so he kind of leans on the field a
little bit more so viewers have always
felt like there was something different
about Cal but now we we know he's pretty
much like the key to solving this thing
how long have you known the significance
of Cal and his story I think since day
one I think he's kind of always been
that pivotal character
um just because he's the innocent he's
the one who has done no wrong all he
does is draws pictures about the future
but he's really the innocent like heart
of the show
um and so for that you get to kind of
see him like lead lead the way
um through that which just funny because
in season one I was like is there like
an omen thing going on with this child
like what's going on here
every good show there's a creepy kid
doing drawings
well let's talk about Zeke because Zeke
makes the ultimate sacrifice for Cal
m
no come on stay with me come on don't
leave me please please no no okay
foreign
how did you react when you read this for
the first time honestly I thought it was
really cool I thought it was great
writing
um you know you get to see why Zeke does
that and how Zeke does that and it just
comes from such a deep place of empathy
and so the fact that it becomes
bigger for Zeke and almost like an
addiction for Zeke and then he gets to
end that addiction with a really good
act or gesture or whatever I thought
that was really great writing how
heart-wrenching was that to film just
knowing like oh I'm saying bye to this
co-star I've worked with for so long I
mean there's no true goodbyes and
manifests I mean and also Zeke has died
so many times that at this point I feel
like good ridden I'm just kidding
um it was horrible the way that we shot
it the Kayla doesn't even have a chance
to say a proper goodbye and so
that was the hard part I think
um just like being in the scene with him
is that she she gets there a little bit
too late but Michaela revealed she had
feelings for Jared at the start of the
Season would you support way there that
was just a pivot right into the other
guy yeah you know
just like that's a little soon but would
you I don't know do you think there's
like a path for them someday besides a
drama it's manifest and feelings aren't
gone like they have been there since day
one Jared and Michaela love each other a
ton and it's been super duper messy but
there's just so much love there that you
can't just walk away from each other are
you personally team Jared or teamsey
everyone asks you this I am Team box for
different reasons I think Zeke is you
know Michaela's Rock and they have this
Supernatural connection that she does
not have of Jared because he hasn't gone
through what they've gone through but
Jared is loyal and he's been there and
they had a history that her and Zeke
don't so it's just it's for different
reasons yeah I've never wanted to see
someone go down harder than Angelina she
is so enjoyed how far can she go like
you you already know the secrets of part
two like she she goes pretty far she
goes pretty pretty far yeah she takes
things dark for sure which character do
you find more aggravating Egan or
Angelina I I kind of loved Egan I think
he's such a menace but like such a
harmless Menace he really is just he
only thinks about himself whereas
Angelina's thinking about herself but
kind of in a bigger picture whereas
Egan's mostly just trying to like get
something in the moment so he's a little
bit more harmless in that way who do you
ship zombie with uh probably Draya oh
they're like off-screen uh they're two
of my closest friends here so it's just
like and and they have such a beautiful
friendship
um I mean we'll see what happens but in
in my perfect world I would end it
together I love that what about them you
know Ben deserves love he absolutely
deserves love and maybe he gets it who
knows but uh his wife just died so I
think we'll give him a second now did
you direct two episodes in part two they
gave me one and it was kind of my uh
first time directing so it was a huge
learning curve but I had so much fun
doing it and um you know we're in season
four slash Five whatever you want to
call it and the whole crew is just so
seamless at this point that I thought it
would be so much harder but everyone
really just wants to make manifest the
best show possible and so it was such an
awesome experience doing it on this show
because I felt so supported and stuff
but um yeah we just had like a group of
creatives really just wanting the best
for the episode for the show so it was a
blast did the move to Netflix do you
feel like changed anything about the
show like are you able to go darker edgy
or anything like that yeah I think we
did a little bit to be honest
um I think there might be one or two
more cuss words in there
um and I think storyline wise it just
feels a bit more relaxed with what we're
able to do
um so it's been fun that's awesome so
the a28ers they realize that the death
day is not just for them but for
everyone 828 wasn't an accident
we're supposed to save the passengers
together
our death date is in 18 months we have
to follow every lead what can you tease
about what happens next on their plan
jeez
um what happens next I mean it's just a
countdown to that that they they're
they're not sure to be honest they're
trying to figure it out
um along with the rest of them and you
know they're finding new creative ways
to get there
um and the stakes just keep getting
higher and higher and so I don't think
they have a plan in mind so much more
just like rolling with the punches and
the punches get harder and harder are
you satisfied by all the answers by the
end of part two yeah I would say fans
would be really really happy with How It
Ends just because it's so it's such a
hard show to wrap up the way our show
runner did it was really beautiful
lack of a better word it's really the
end correct I think it really is yeah I
mean who knows in this day and age there
could be a spin-off there could be a
Side Story we could go dive back into
something else but as of right now I I
think this is where we are leaving it
what is your message to fans who have
been long awaiting this next chapter the
season four one thank you for helping us
get here because we really wouldn't be
without them
um and uh two I just I hope that they
enjoy it as much as we had like we had
so much fun filming it that I hope they
enjoy it to the same degree because
there are some people that have been
with us since day one like even some of
the background that we had on our show
have been there since day one and so it
really just feels like a collective
including the fans so I'm just excited
for them to see it
[Music]
foreign